il a fallu attendre les années 50 quand
le royaume himalayen s'est ouvert aux
étrangers pour qu'on découvre ses
paysages à couper le souffle qui attire
randonneurs et alpinistes de partout son
mont everest le plus haut du monde a
fait la gloire des monnaies et le riz le
premier à le gravir avec l'aide de son
sherpa népalais et la capitale katmandou
a longtemps fait le bonheur des hippies
le haschisch et la marijuana y étaient
en vente libre jusque dans les années 70
aujourd'hui en dépit du tourisme les
népalais sont parmi les plus pauvres du
monde
le revenu annuel moyen dépasse à peine
les 1200 dollars selon le fmi
ils ont espéré de meilleures conditions
de vie quand le royaume est passé à une
démocratie parlementaire en 1990 mais
les communistes maoïstes ont pris la
tête d'une insurrection qui a fait la
guerre aux forces gouvernementales
pendant dix ans après des semaines de
manifestations populaires en 2006 les
deux parties ont baissé les armes et
depuis les gouvernements de coalition se
succèdent sans réussir à s'entendre sur
le texte d'une constitution
il faut dire que le népal est très varié
démographiquement et culturellement
c'est 30 millions d'habitants se divise
en dizaines d'ethnies et de castes mais
sont majoritairement de religion hindoue
katmandou reflète cette diversité
plusieurs monuments lié à l'hindouisme
mais aussi au bouddhisme certains
construit au 12e siècle et classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco sont
aujourd'hui détruit un des plus vieux
monument bouddhiste le stupa bouddha nat
et gravement endommagé
geneviève asselin icera du canada
montréal